there's something in stockfield that
makes traveling in space way better
because it requires less use of menus it
took me a lot longer to figure out than
I care to admit which means it may also
have happened to you basically if you
bring up your scanner and scan on a
planet and then you just look at it you
will actually be able to from the scan
menu then select to land on something
instead of having to actually open up
the menu go to the planet map screen and
select it from there I've been doing
this in my own streams a ton but this
footage is from you huggin00 on Reddit
it shows you exactly how it works this
works when you're looking at a planet
but this example is actually for grab
jumping between systems which is extra
cool and it works effectively the same
way on Console as it works on PC